monsieur tong bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
alors après plus de deux mois de
confinement une chute de la croissance
chinoise était prévisible et elle aussi
importante qu'attendue au mieux vu
l'ampleur des mesures de confinement de
dollars et d'économie vraiment vieillir
à trous c'est une question politique ce
que d'arrêter aussi bien la production
est de 2 et que ça les conséquences
penser de moi donc moi ce qui se fait de
8%
ce n'est pas surprenant ceci dit york
entre temps il ya eu quand même des
chiffres un peu plus encourageants
si on prend ce qu'on appelle la dce inde
et des directeurs d'achat le pee wee de
fin mars
en fait de l'indicateur qui qualifie d'
indicateurs avancés qui projette un peu
vers le futur le lundi ce ça a progressé
à progresser par rapport à celui de
février qui devint très très bas on est
retourné dans la zone d'expansion
ça veut dire que l'activité économique
reprend doucement certes mais quand même
de manière remarquable par rapport à vos
plus fort de la crise de cannabis en
chine notamment la consommation parce
que malgré tout de toute une partie de
la chine a connu des allégements mesure
les consignes mans bien avant la
province de couper et dans de grandes
villes shanghai tianjin
les gens sont ressortis ont commencé à
consommer de plus en plus certain nombre
d'établissements ou couvert les
commerces les restaurants
donc effectivement on peut s'attendre à
ce que la consommation rattrape le
retard
il y aura une sorte de frénésie des
envies de consommer de la part des gens
comme est consignée pendant trop
longtemps ce qui est explicable
de toute façon quand on verra dans les
mois qui viennent un chiffre remonter ce
serait pas étonnant parce qu'on partir
là d'une base statistique qui est quand
même très très basse après le moins 6 2
8% alors le fmi prévoit quand même pour
l'année 2020 une croissance encore
positive la chine certes
pour le moment l'estimation 1 2%
seulement
mais pour 2021 le fmi prévoit une
remontée spectaculaire du cmi chinoise
là encore c'est un effet de deux
optiques sont reprochés espérer une
reprise de 2 de l'économie et de la
croissance ça sera donc fin 2021 début
2022 pour la chine je pense que dans la
deuxième moitié de 2020 les choses ils
ont déjà beaucoup mieux en 2021
parce que si l'écart est un peu liées à
la conjoncture internationale
certes le commerce international ne
représente pas une part prépondérante de
la croissance chinoise
mais la chine dépend quand même de la
conjoncture internationale il faut voir
que la croissance chinoise ayant à peu
près à hauteur de 10% du commerce
international de ses exportations et là
dessus l'incertitude qui règne sur le
marché américain et européen est
pénalisant bientôt bien sûr pour pour la
croissance chinoise
qu'est-ce que j'ai quels sont les
secteurs d'activité précisément qui
souffrent le plus des conséquences de ce
confinement
c'est l'exploitation bien sûr celui là
c'est internationale donc tout ce qui
marche et domestiques
on peut avoir un peu confiance qu'on
peut avoir confiance parce que
finalement la tour mettre finalement de
l'économie chinoise c'est la taille de
son marché domestique
c'est unique dans le monde aujourd'hui
la chine peut se contenter comme d'un
marché domestique gigantesque qui est la
base la consommation domestique en chine
et la base de croissance chinoise en or
de sa ya aussi tout ce qui est
investissements dans les infrastructures
alors ils peuvent encore faire beaucoup
dans les infrastructures des villes des
nouveaux ennemis aussi dans le centre du
pays
mais tout ce qu'ils connaissent
extérieur voilà nos certitudes parce que
ça ne dépend pas d'eux mais encore une
fois ça ne représente pas plus de 10%
finalement de l'économie chinoise
aujourd'hui très bien merci beaucoup
monsieur jean-paul chang d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes etc
l'istat